We.
We're back from St John's,
the site
where the Titans started
its ill fated journey
as the investigation picks up here.
A search for answers
is happening
for another deadly sea
disaster, this one in the Mediterranean
and where more than 700
migrants were crammed on a boat
that sank last week off
the coast of Greece.
And the testimonies
from survivors
depict chaos and desperation.
An investigation
by CNN's Jomana
Karadsheh raises some questions
about the statements from Greek officials
about what actually led to this tragedy.
The desperate,
exhausting week
for the promise of a new life in Europe.
These Pakistanis
crammed into a small room by smugglers
in Libya.
Some of them believed to be among
the hundreds presumed dead.
These last images
before they embarked
on their Ill-Fated journey.
About 750 refugees
and migrants were packed into this
fishing vessel bound for Italy
before it capsized off the
coast of Greece.
Only 104 survived.
And with
them,
the harrowing accounts of what
they'd been through for them all along.
I can still hear the voice of a woman
calling out for help.
You would swim
and move the floating bodies
out of your way.
The Syrian survivor
spoke to us from Greece.
He asked for his identity
to be concealed for security reasons.
His and other accounts
obtained by CNN
not only contradict
the official Greek version of events,
but point to fault
on the part of the Greek Coast Guard.
Greek authorities who watched
and were communication with the boat
for an entire day in insist
that it was not in distress
and refused assistance.
Our investigation
tells a very different story
Just before one p.
M on June 13th,
the boat was first spotted by the U.S.
Border Patrol agency Frontex,
which says it
notified Greek authorities
of a, quote, heavily
overcrowded fishing vessel.
Those on board were in distress,
lost at sea
with no food or water for days,
according to survivors and activists.
In touch with the boat
throughout the day.
At about 7 p.m., an activist
in Italy recorded
one of the calls,
capturing the horror on board.
I'm going.
I'm going to happen.
That was going to happen
as activists
repeatedly relayed calls for a rescue
to authorities
to merchant
vessels, approached the boats
instructed by the Greek Coast Guard
to provide the boat with food and water.
But as darkness fell at 10:40 p.m.
a Greek Coast Guard vessel moves in.
Now the only ship on the scene
3 hours later,
the haunting last words
from the boat to the activist
group alarmed phone.
Hello, my friend.
The ship you send is the line cuts out.
What happened
next is likely to raise more questions
as the investigations continue.
Survivors
tell us it was a botched attempt
by the Greek Coast Guard
to tow their boat
that caused it to capsize
and they decided to throw as a rope.
So the guys at the front tied it.
They told us
the boat tilted to the right
and everyone was screaming.
People began falling into the sea
and the boat capsized.
People couldn't
get out from under the boat.
The Greek Coast Guard
have declined our request
for an interview,
but in previous comments,
they've denied towing the trawler, saying
when the boat capsized,
we were not even next to it.
How could we be towing it?
Instead, they blamed a shift in weight,
probably caused by panic
For years, Greek authorities
have been accused of systematically
and violently
pushing back migrants and refugees.
Video like this one released
by the Turkish government
captured the now
well documented practice.
Greece denies
this deadly incident is not just about
what they may have done.
It's also about what they didn't do.
It was clear it was unseaworthy.
It was clear that it is
part of the offshore trafficking movement
from Libya to Europe.
So the authorities had a responsibility
to intervene, to save life.
As Fortress
Europe hardens
its immigration policies to deter
some of the world's most vulnerable.
This disaster will almost certainly
not be the last
And, Anderson, as you heard there, Greek
authorities are telling us
that they're continuing
to investigate this incident.
But the Greek Coast
Guard, Greek authorities in the past over
the past few years
have been
accused of violently pushing back
migrants and refugees.
And we've never really seen any results
of investigations in the past.
So the question right now
is whether there should be any sort
of an international
independent investigation. Anderson,
yeah, this has been going on and on.
Jomana Karadsheh, I appreciate it.
Thank you.